>> THIS WEEK THE DEMOCRATS
REALLY CONTAINED IN SELF WHEN
THEY THOUGHT THEY FOUND THE
SMOKING GUN ON IMPEACHMENT.
>> I THINK IS VERY DAMNING AND I
THINK IT PUTS A POLITICALLY AT
THIS PRESIDENCY.
>> DEVASTATING TO DONALD TRUMP
READ THE MOST DISTURBING DIRT IN
CONGRESS.
>> SHOCKING.
>> SHOCKING, DEVASTATING, THESE
PEOPLE ARE RIDICULOUS.
WHAT GOT THEM SO EXCITED, BILL
TAYLOR, OUR AMBASSADOR TO
UKRAINE THAT CLAIMED THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO WITHHOLD
MILITARY UNLESS THE NEW
PRESIDENT PUBLICLY SAID HE'S
INVESTIGATING NOT JUST 2016
ELECTION MEDDLING BUT THE BIDENS
TOO.
HIS CLAIM IS ALSO IN PUBLISHED
WITNESS STATEMENTS.
WHAT IS THE TRUTH, WE DON'T KNOW
ALL OF IT BECAUSE THE WHOLE
THING IS STILL BEING RUN IN
SECRET, THE REPUBLICANS CALLING
OUT LED TO A NEW TALKING POINT
TO DEMOCRATS AND TRUMP HATING
MEDIA.
THE FACTOR BACK FOR THE
PRESIDENT, THAT IS NONSENSE AND
HERE IS WHY.
WE HAVE FACTS, ONE THERE WAS
NOTHING NEW IN BILL TAYLOR'S
TESTIMONY, ESSENTIALLY HE
EMBELLISHED WE HEARD WEEKS AGO
WHEN A BUNCH OF TEXT MESSAGES
WERE LEAKED.
TWO, WHEN TAYLOR WAS QUESTION
ABOUT HIS QUID PRO QUO, HIS
STORY FELL APART, HERE'S
REPUBLICAN JOHN.
>> TO CAMERON KRAFT WANTED TO
BELIEVE HIS TESTIMONY WOULD
SUPPORT WITH THE WAS A BLUR SAID
WHEN IN FACT HIS TESTIMONY
ESTABLISHED OPPOSITE.
STEVE: BILL TAYLOR STORY WAS
ALSO CONTRADICTED BY ANOTHER
DIPLOMAT JOSE
DIPLOMAT JOSÉ INVOLVED IN ALL OF
THIS CURRENT BROKER, HE WAS
INTERVIEWED BY THE IMPEACHMENT
COMMITTEE WEEKS AGO.
BUT YOU DID NOT HEAR THE
DEMOCRATS JUMPING UP AND DOWN
ABOUT THAT.
BECAUSE AS WE TOLD YOU WEEKS AGO
HIS EVIDENT EXONERATED PRESIDENT
TRUMP ON THE MAIN IMPEACHMENT
CHARGES.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE DEMOCRATS LOVE
FOR THE GREEN DIPLOMAT HAVE
FALLEN OVER AND EXTENDS AS FAR
TO GET PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS WAS NOT THE SMOKING GUN,
BILL TAYLOR IS A BUS, HE COULD
BILL TAYLOR IS A BUS, HE CLALD
BILL TAYLOR IS A BUS, HE CLAIMS
HE'S NOT BIASED.
THAT'S NOT THE POINT.
THIS IS ABOUT POPULIST VERSUS
ESTABLISHMENT.
INSIDE NOT REPUBLICAN VERSUS
DEMOCRAT, IS SYSTEM STRIKING
BACK, OF COURSE BILL TAYLOR IS
POLITICAL AND BIASED JUST LIKE
ALL THE CAREER CIVIL SERVICE
COMING OUT OF THE WOODWORK.
THEY WANT POWER WITHOUT
ACCOUNTABLE THE IN THE VERY
PEOPLE WHO LECTURED US BUT THESE
BUREAUCRATS ON PEDESTAL EXTENT
OF EXPOSING THEM FOR WHAT THEY
ARE.
THEY WERE TRAINED TO TAKE THE
PRESIDENT CHALLENGING THE SYSTE
SYSTEM.
FINALLY BILL TAYLOR IS SUCH A
FINE OUTSTANDING UNBIASED
SERVICE OF THE PEOPLE, WHY THE
HELL DID HE NOT CALL ON
UKRAINE'S TWO INVESTIGATE THE
BIDENS, JOE BIDEN BOASTED ABOUT
CONTROLLING AID TO UKRAINE.
>> I SAID YOU ARE NOT GETTING IT
AND I THINK IT WAS SIX HOURS.
AND THE PROSECUTOR IS NOT FIRE,
YOU'RE NOT GETTING THE MONEY,
[BLEEP]
>> THE REAL SCANDAL IS NOT THE
FIRING OF THE PROSECUTOR, IT IS
CASH, BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
U.S. TAXPAYER CASH CONTROLLED BY
JOE BIDEN GOING TO UKRAINIAN
ENERGY INCLUDING FOR HIS MOM
WHERE HIS SON WAS ON THE BOARD.
HOW MUCH TAXPAYER MONEY DID HE
GIVE TO A BITING FAMILY
BUSINESS.
WHY DIDN'T BILL TAYLOR LOOK INTO
THAT, BECAUSE ALONG WITH BIDEN
HE IS PART OF THE ESTABLISHMENT
AND THIS IS HOW THEY ROLL, BY
THE WAY ALL THESE DEMOCRATS
SAYING IT DAMAGES NATIONAL
SECURITY TO HOLD UP UKRAINE
MILITARY AID.
WE DID THAT FIRST YOUR PRESIDENT
PRESSURE IS OBAMA.
HE REFUSED AT ALL, IT WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO DID, THIS
WHOLE PART OF THE IMPEACHMENT IS
THE BIGGEST CROCK OF YOU KNOW
WHAT SINCE THE LAST ONE THEY PUT
OUT.
THEY CONSUME THIS COUNTRY FOR
TWO YEARS AND IT
TWO YEARS AND PT
TWO YEARS AND PROVED TO BE
NOTHING.
THEY HATE TRUMP, THEY HATE YOU
FOR VOTING FOR HIM IN 2016 AND
THAT TERRIFIED THAT YOUR WE
ELECT HIM IN 2020 BECAUSE HE IS
THE ECONOMY BOOMING AND DELIVERS
PROMISES.
FINALLY, THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT PERSONALLY.
IT'S ABOUT HIS POLICY AGENDA IN
THE POPULIST MOVEMENT.
THE SYSTEM IS STRIKING BACK,
THEY ARE TRYING TO CRUSH THE
POPULACE REVOLUTION AND WE HAVE